-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Kenan Thompson.
This is really cool,
speaking about
how long you've been
on the show.
Aubrey Plaza hosting this week,
the fantastic Aubrey Plaza,
was, in 2004,
when we were both there,
an intern in the set department.
-Is that not crazy?
-What a trip.
Now the interns are coming back.
That's how long
you've been there.
-Yeah, I know.
So I'm going to start hurting
at some point.
-Yeah. I will say --
and I think this reflects
very well on you --
this is a real reminder --
be nice to the interns,
which I'm sure
you always have been.
-1,000%.
Like, all this week,
I've been like,
"I feel like I was nice to her,
but do I know for sure?"
-We all do have bad days,
but it's a real mistake
to take it out on the interns,
because just based on, you know,
life expectancy,
they're going to be around
after we're long gone.
We were talking about --
You know,
I have authors
on the show a lot.
-Yes, you do.
-And you were lamenting the fact
that you've never been on
to talk about your book,
because I, of course,
did not know --
or certainly assumed that
you hadn't written a book,
but you actually have been
writing books.
-Yes, I've been dabbling in the
world of authoring, if you will.
And, yeah, I'm very excited to
present some of my work
here tonight.
-And you write under a pen name.
-I do. A full pen name.
-Okay.
Would you like to leave
and have me introduce you
as your pen name?
-Oh, that's fun.
Yeah, can we do that?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay, go ahead.
-Okay, I'm going.
Okay, I'll be right back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is really exciting,
everybody.
Our next guest is
a science-fiction writer
with the third
in his "Quark" series.
Please welcome the author of
"Quinsley's Nebula,"
Pernice LaFonk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my God.
Mr. LaFonk, what an honor
to have you here.
-Sethly, it is
an honor and a privilege
to be graced with your presence,
as well, my friend.
-Now, you are
a science-fiction writer.
Where do you get
your wonderful ideas about
space and these
fantastic characters?
-Oh, the cosmos provides.
The cosmos
most definitely provides.
And I would just love to
read a bit of my...
-Do you want to read a passage?
-...my work.
-Well, here we go.
This is so exciting.
And I've read all the books
in the "Quark" series,
so this is very exciting.
-And you respect mine.
Thank you very much.
Wonderful.
[ Clears throat ]
The name of the book is
"Quinsley's Nebula."
Here is a passage from
Chapter 13, "Beta 4."
-Your chapters always have
the most wonderful titles.
-Yes. Big fan of "Star Wars."
"There is thunder
on the planet Persephone 9."
Mm.
"But it makes not the cracking
sound it does on Earth.
Rather,
it makes a different noise
every...single...time.
No sound of thunder ever repeats
on this barren planet,
a fact that
Captain Grax Pendlesmith
was unaware of as he steered
his ship to an uneasy landing
amidst the swirling storm.
'Kerflank!'
went the thunder as
his trusty ship, the Pegaseuss,
lurched to the right.
'Ba-klamp!' went the next,
followed by a
'Paloma,' 'Shalamar,'
and, finally, 'Futhermucker.'"
Thank you. Thank you very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good times.
-So wonderful.
-Thank you very much.
-And, now, you are doing
a book signing at
Barnes & Noble tonight?
-Not tonight.
Very early in the morning,
if you wouldn't mind
showing up at 5:00 a.m.
I will be there promptly
at 5:07.
-Now, I don't even think
Barnes & Noble
is open that early.
Are you doing it outside
the Barnes & Noble?
-If it's ideal, on the sidewalk.
-So you're doing
a book signing on the sidewalk
outside of Barnes & Noble.
-Yes. I'm very brave.
Very brave.
And I'm looking forward to it.
Also, I will be introducing
my following, follow-up book,
"Amazon Boobies on the Moon."
[ Laughter ]
So look out for that series.
-Where did you get that idea?
-I think in the shower.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, what do you smoke?
Could I just ask
real quick, Pernice,
what do you usually smoke?
-I think you know.
I think you know.
We don't want to --
-And this is very exciting.
I know that Netflix
is adapting this into a series,
and there is some really
exciting casting news you have.
-Is that happening?
Oh.
I wasn't aware of that.
I'm very excited
to hear their plans.
-Do you even
have a Netflix account?
-And could you explain,
what is this Netflix, exactly?
This is fun.
-Pernice LaFonk, you, of course,
are also Kenan Thompson.
You are a dear friend.
Give it up one more time...
[ Cheers and applause ]
for Kenan, everybody.
"SNL" returns and this week with
host Aubrey Plaza
and musical guest Sam Smith.
We'll be right back with
Jinkx Monsoon.